the world's first elevator shaft was
installed four years before the elevator
was invented which sounds ridiculous but
inside this building the Cooper Union
foundation building in New York City is
the world's first elevator shaft the
first time a building was constructed to
have a space for an elevator
top-to-bottom because when this was
being designed in the 1850s the
architect and owner looked at New York
City just starting to sprawl wider and
rise higher and they predicted someone
is going to invent the safe passenger
elevator soon four years later Elisha
Otis did just that
but that prediction wasn't quite perfect
I think the remarkable thing about the
foundation building is that Peter Cooper
first recognized that he needed to build
a building and then that he would figure
out what he wanted to do with it there
were principles that he was committed to
one was free education to the
working-class people of New York
he established a free reading room
before there were public libraries also
the largest interior space in New York
City in which to hold lectures and
debates also open for free to the
general public
Peter Cooper's vision was both for a
very radical progressive institution but
he wanted embedded in the building
radical new technologies and ideas so by
this time by 1850 New York City was
still really really crowded and dense
but the grid of Manhattan had already
been laid out the Manhattan grid was
established in 1811 so everyone in New
York City understood that New York City
was going to grow and it was growing in
the middle of the century exponentially
in fact the population of Manhattan
would peak in 1910 and we still have not
reached the density and the high
population that the city had at that
time so Peter Cooper knew that the city
had to be able to grow outward but it
also had to be able to grow upward so he
knew the elevator was coming at the same
time Elisha Otis who we all know
from the Otis Elevator Company was busy
working on not inventing an elevator
because the elevator had been in use for
centuries to move equipment to move
goods what
Otis understood was that elevators would
never be used for people until they were
safe so what he was working on doing is
to invent the safety elevator that's
happening in 1855 the foundation
building meanwhile is under construction
so Peter Cooper knew this was coming
the only thing nobody knew was what
would be the shape of the elevator cab
and Peter Cooper bet on circular since
it's the most efficient way spatially to
put the most number of people in the
smallest shaft and to carry them
vertically little did he know that
that was not going to be the
conventional elevator cab shape and so
this was the first elevator shaft that
was constructed we think worldwide
certainly in the city but it was not the
first functioning elevator and the
elevator cab that was ultimately put in
this shaft was Square so it was
literally a square peg in a round hole
the building was renovated really from
top to bottom on the inside in 1975 the
architect John Hajduk makes sure that
the round shaft is really floating in
the space and the other thing he does is
he makes a companion elevator diagonally
across the floor which is a square
elevator I always thought that that was
you know a beautiful way to allow
architecture to speak across time Peter
Cooper's intuition that the shape would
be round was not what the market would
carry forward when you're thinking ahead
of your time
sometimes you will guess correctly and
sometimes
you won't but taking the risk to
actually invent something new and to
build it into a building I think is
really an innovative idea is it worth
the risk of making that sort of
prediction when it is basically just a
gamble give him what hassle a round
elevator shaft turned out to be was it
worth it or would it have been better to
wait and then retrofit a regular
elevator in later like every other
buildings in that era and here's a
bigger question what should we'll be
designing for now not just in buildings
but anywhere what's the thing that is
going to seem obvious in 20 or 30 years
but no one would see coming I don't know
maybe you do
you